Throughout human evolution,
eyes have been vital to our survival.
They've evolved to be round
so that they can swivel
to spot delicious prey
and easily roll when your cousin
talks about his new car
for the third time.
But to get to that point,
our peepers have come a long way.
They most likely developed from
a tiny light-sensitive patch
on single-celled organisms that
would help them move towards light
in the hope of finding food.
As the creatures evolved,
this patch started to curve inward
to better focus light. And now, a
whole bunch of evolution later,
what we've arrived at
are two twinkling spheres
that are capable of seeing
about a million colours.
Not bad, eh?
We might actually be on
to something with that
'window to the soul' stuff too,
as our eyes can portray more about
our emotions than you might think.
Your pupils dilate when you're
scared, nervous or excited.
That could be why they enlarge
when we make eye contact
with someone we, like,
like-like.
Research has also shown that
even making eye contact with
a portrait painting sets off
a whole raft of brain activity.
Our eyes are also responsible for
another universal emotional reaction
- a good old weep.
But we actually have
three types of tears,
each with their own
chemical makeup.
Basal, which lubricate the eye.
Reflex tears, caused by irritants
like dust or chopped onions.
And psychic, or emotional tears,
the kind that appear when
you find out about Bambi's mum
for the first time.
When it comes to our pupils, it's not
just the size of them that varies -
the shape of an animal's pupils
can tell us if it's predator or prey.
Some have horizonal pupils,
making them more adept at scanning
for predators while
munching on grass...
found on your local
goats, sheep, and moose.
Vertical pupils like those found
on foxes, cats and crocodiles
are better for ambushing and hunting
at night, and have become synonymous
with animals that you just
do not want to mess with.
Our round pupils are
kind of a best of both worlds
and help us in active foraging
and chasing down prey.
Which, you know,
we totally do, all the time.
There are quite a few animals who do
a better job of seeing than we do.
The elephant hawk-moth,
which sounds like that band
your dad might have been in,
was the first animal proven
to be able to see colour
in the dead of night.
Their large, sensitive eyes
allow the maximum
available light to pass through.
However, this does impact their
ability to detect fast-moving objects
like a rolled-up newspaper.
Human eyes might not be perfect.
Parts of them are even useless,
like that little pink bit
in the inner corners.
\N
That's the remains of a third eyelid
like the ones cats,
dogs and camels have.
Our eyes aren't just physically
interesting, but culturally too.
Much loved by conspiracy theorists
the world over, The Eye of Horus
may symbolise the Illuminati to some,
but its origins lie in Egypt
where the eye is a symbol
representing sacrifice,
healing and protection.
In Turkey, some believe that
a sideways glance can cause
genuine pain.
And thinking back to high school,
they're not wrong.
Glass pendants, also eye-shaped,
are worn to protect
against this evil eye.
So whether round, monolid, hooded,
downturned, upturned or almond,
words you're probably familiar with
if you spend as much time watching
makeup tutorials as me,
your eyes are unique to you.
The two are even unique
to each other.
But one thing does unite us all...
we can't for the life of us
keep them open when we sneeze.